are you ready for it Taylor Swift is
giving the world front row seats to her
rep tour that's right you guys the
singer announced at the last show of the
US leg of the highest-selling tour in US
history is coming to Netflix on December
31st without your past you could never
have arrived here the epic concert will
have all the things you guys want pyro
fireworks multiple stages appearances by
Camila caballo and Charli XCX and of
course that 63 foot Cobra named Karen
Karen I love Karen after the exciting
news broke Taylor took to Instagram
writing in part quote today I finally
get to show you something we've been
working on for a while
you made this tour so insanely fun for
all of us on stage and I'm really
excited that we will have this memento
of the memories we all made together
this year you're the best thank you for
everything I am so glad they're doing
this because I got to tell you guys I
went to her tour in May at the Rose Bowl
and it was the night of the royal
weddings we had worked all night the
night before so by the time our concert
started I was a little delirious so I
remember it but I can't wait to relive
it and be like ah yes was it as awesome
as everyone said it was yes oh my gosh
her stage presence is just undeniable it
is so good I have a confession guys I
did not go to the Taylor concert I
wanted to the tickets were so expensive
and I'm glad I held out because now I
get to see it up close and personal for
free and I love Taylor for making this
show accessible to everybody this is a
classic Taylor move she's always doing
whatever she can for her fans which is
something that she actually told ET
before her 1989 World Tour I truly want
it to be a different experience for the
fans I want the technology to be
different the stage the lighting the
screens the cast of dancers and people
that they see on stage I want them to be
dressed differently than they've ever
seen them and I just honestly I'm so
excited and so proud that we've gotten
to that place now where I realize this
is a very unique tour compared to what
we've done in true swiftie fashion they
announced the news on her 29th birthday
have a birthday
yeah happy birthday it's not the only
Taylor news making headlines though
Rolling Stone reported that at her
concert at the Rose Bowl in California
on May 18th
fans were monitored with facial
recognition technology as they stared at
screens broadcasting footage of Taylor
rehearsing Mike downing was a chief
security officer for Oak View group told
the mag that the images captured at the
concert were transmitted to a command
post in Nashville quote everyone who
went by would stop and stare at it and
the software would start working that is
way more advanced than I thought was
real Swift spaces were then reportedly
cross-referenced against a list of her
stalkers interesting is this an invasion
of privacy or just a necessary security
move let us know yeah of course we
should keep in mind that in April a man
was arrested after breaking into her
apartment the NYPD found him asleep
inside the apartment we should note that
Taylor did not live at that property and
was not there at the time of the
break-in but it's still definitely still
scary and I would definitely shake me up
early this month he was sentenced to six
months in a prison but let's end this on
a happy note it's Taylor's birthday
she's 29 last year of her 20s make it a
good one you're ready for it until next
time a badass car awesome time at Hawley
underscore Stephens